bin heute in die sendung kommen ich will
sie ja das ist gleich dazu dazu auch
einen selbstkritischen satz ich bin
heutige sendung gekommen um mit ihnen
mein mitgefühl mit boris becker zu
teilen für mich ist boris becker
deutsches kulturgut und mit kulturgut
geht man pfleglich um ich finde wir
haben die verdammte oder besser gesagt
die heilige fliegt wo bis vor den folgen
seines ruhmes in schutz zu nehmen dieses
ganze land hat kollektiv von boris
becker besitz ergriffen als er mit 17
diesen historischen wahlsieg errungen
hat er wurde zu unser aller adoptivsohn
und jetzt haben wir eine fürsorgepflicht
für diesen top teams und wir haben
dadurch dass wir ihn so hochgejubelt
haben alle dazu beigetragen dass er
superstar den bezug zur realität
verloren hat und dadurch verbietet sich
jetzt jede häme ich fordere solidarität
am liebsten wäre männer ein
auslieferungsgesuch an großbritannien
boris hat es nicht verdient zweieinhalb
jahren diesen abscheulichen
mittelalterlichen knast in londons word
zu schmachten er soll an uns überstellt
werden damit er zweieinhalb jahre auf
staatskosten in einem deutschen
fünf-sterne-hotel eingesperrt gerne er
kann ja auch eine fußfessel bekommen und
jetzt zu geld jetzt zu jetzt zu dem was
über sie gesagt lambertz knast ich habe
mich an dem tag ich bin ich bin ein
treuer loyaler redakteur der bild
zeitung ja ich habe mich an diesem
morgen richtig geärgert über unsere
schlagzeile spiel satz knast ich fange
das war das war hämisch und hat mich
dann gefreut dann auf seite 2 den den
empathischen kommentar von franz wagner
zu lesen der ihn seit er 17 jahre alt
ist kennt ich finde überhaupt unser
umgang mit unseren helden etwas
befremdlich ich finde mir ging es mit
uli hoeneß ist auch schon sowie zwei
sich dass uli hoeneß das 1 1 eine figur
ist die sehr spaltet mir ging das bei
franz beckenbauer so ich fahre unter
umgang mit franz beckenbauer auch nicht
okay wir gehen jetzt mit jan ullrich
ähnlich ich finde und ich frage mich
manchmal woran das liegt ich glaube
langsam mehr verdacht dass wir darauf
dass wir dazu neigen zu vergessen dass
auch stars menschen sind und man muss
doch immer dieses dieser knast im
wandsworth nicht mehr vorstellen der ist
unterirdisch kein kein deutsches
gefängnis
ich würde solche zustände gedulden da
würden
das ist unwahr diese gefängnisse in
england zum teil aus dem 19 jahrhundert
der hat eine kloschüssel im raum und da
kann nicht mal ein vorhang zuziehen ich
finde es unmöglich sind die deutschen so
viel luxus wer für luxuriöser und ich
hörte noch mal und noch mal kurz zu
einen organisten was wird
er hat etwas besser ein zu seinen
delikten gehörte interessanterweise
etwas hoch anständige sie hatte mich
versucht seiner mutter das haus zu
bewahren das 1 1 der vermögenswerte die
eher versteckt hat war dieses haus in
laim und wo seine mutter drin wohnt das
hat eher versteckt weil er sehr
vielleicht auch niemals sein dürfen aber
ich möchte trotzdem daran erinnern wie
gesagt dass das motiv seinem seiner
mutter an seiner alten mutter das hat
dass das davor davor zu bewahren dass
ihr haus verliert und irgendwie als alte
dame plötzlich auf der straße landet ist
jetzt erstmal etwas das das spricht für
mildernde umstände nach meinen nach
meinem dafürhalten also ich finde mich
stört
die hirne und ich habe großen respekt
vor rosberg und ich muss sagen unsere
leser haben ein sehr sehr gut wir haben
sogar heute in der bild eine ganze seite
gemacht mit leserbriefen und ich muss
sagen ich bin begeistert von unseren
lesern nicht immer von unserer eigenen
redaktionellen leistungen wird dieses
schlags den eigenen leuten und dann
gehts aber eine diskussion über buch ist
das nicht sagt rainer buckel aus
neufahrn in bayern libor ist das
wichtigste nach einer niederlage egal ob
ein poker tennis oder im leben ist es
wieder aufzustehen weiter zu kämpfen und
ein sein comeback zu glauben viel kraft
dafür du schaffst das das ist das ist
finde ich man sieht dass unsere leser
seien ganz gesundes gespür haben okay
klar habe ich ein bisschen
erstmal finde ich es toll dass man sich
über die schlagzeile auch ärgern kann
ich habe mich über die schlagzeile
gefreut weil sie nämlich was
kenianisches tut ich habe die gar nicht
als häme empfunden sondern sie ersetzt
ja das wort sieg durch das wort knast
und das sind die beiden pole in der
karriere von boris becker also
nachgerade sind dieser genial ischen 2
das heißt du warst in der konferenz
sind diese kenianischen zeile sind ist
quasi boris beckers leben er einmal er
in seiner ganzen tragik in seiner ganzen
höhe und tiefe gefasst das aber
sozusagen fast nur in klammern ich bin
natürlich gegen häme aber ich bin schon
dafür dass straftäter ihrer gerechten
strafe zugeführt werden müssen und
deshalb sind auch die beispiele der
beispiele die sogenannte von prominenten
und im umgang mit prominenten nicht ganz
wirklich eine reihe also uli hoeneß
straftäter boris becker straftäter bei
jan ullrich erinnere ich mich an keine
straftat ist sozusagen er in morales in
menschliche situation hineinbekommen
klar hat er hat betrogen beim radfahren
aber das ist das ist irgendwie was
anderes ich glaube dass also ich liebe
dein impuls und dass wir uns immer
fragen müssen wie gehen wir mit diesen
instanzen mit dem kulturgut um ich finde
aber bei dem der kleine strafe beim
strafrecht ist eine grenze und jetzt
kommt der punkt in ich fühle dabei ich
finde ich sehe ihn auch nicht
gerechterweise in diesem gefängnis also
weil ich sehen auch übrigens nicht in
dem fünf sterne hotel sondern es ist ich
sehe auch nicht mit fußfesseln was
diskutiert worden ist warum also das
strafmaß ist nur zweieinhalb jahre und
da wird er 15 monate davon im gefängnis
sein und dann kann einmal nachdenken
warum er so pummelig so dusselig so
deutlich oder so vorsätzlich war wie das
gericht ihm sozusagen nachgewiesen hat
dass
da ist eine grenze und die die zu
verwässern durch zu viel ich habe ja so
eine leichte ironische zuspitzung schon
erkannt in deiner in deiner diese aber
die zu verwässern an der stelle mit zu
viel kult und damit auch eine straftat
zu relativieren finde ich schwierig dass
jemand zweieinhalb jahre kriegt weil er
im großen stil muss man zugeben aber ein
ein geld liegt begangen hat und wir
manchmal menschen das sehen die anderen
menschen körperlich was antun die licht
zweieinhalb jahre ins gefängnis müssen
das stört mich ist aber leider ein alter
ein alter gegenstand in der
auseinandersetzung mit mit dem
rechtssystem das
vergehen oder taten gegen das eigentum
in der tendenz brutaler bestraft werden
als
körperverletzung bzw das stört mich
daran ihr jetzt öffentlich meine die
diskussion aber entwicklung etwas kürzer
verantwortung schaffen wir heute nicht
mehr alle wünsche hast und dann auch sie
herr petzner moll tage ist boris becker
nun ein held oder ein verbrecher sitzt
er zu recht im knast wie sind ihre
empfindungen
wir sagen ist ein gefallener held
also ich teile völlig sein ihre
wut an ihre emotionen gegen diese ham ja
also das dass man dann noch emotional
nachtritt und der ist die gleichen die
ihn vorher in den himmel geschossen
haben jetzt sich über in eifern
verdammen so das ist mir alles viel zu
viel überschuss aber ich glaube es gibt
einen punkt
den sie gemacht haben
herr strunz man kann ihn nicht aus
seiner verantwortung entlassen
ja und er ist für sein leben und für
sein handeln verantwortlich wie jeder
andere bürger und bürgerinnen auch und
die tatsache dass er ein nationaler
heroes war dass die die nation zu füßen
lag und der einen antenne genie war kann
ihnen davon nicht entlasten
ob jetzt gestorben ich habe diesen
prozess verfolgt ich bin jetzt zufällig
in dieser runde hier gerade die
straße
oder andere das kann ich gar nicht sagen
beurteilen aber ich glaube dass er eben
auch zu den besten auch wieder an
ullrich gehört die mit weder dem ruhm
noch dem reichtum wirklich sagen auch
wenn ja dann kommen der einmal nach
einem zuhören fertigt momentan ich muss
nur kurz einfach es gibt ja viele stars
und jetzt mal die häme auszuweiten zum
beispiel die sängerin nena die wird ja
auch mit häme überschüttet ihre songs
dürfen nicht mehr oder weil vielen
radiostation nicht mehr laufen wie sehen
sie das denn insgesamt den umgang mit
prominenten in deutschland ob wir
heimisch sind ja wir sind ja auch
leitkultur volk also durch und durch
also das ist leider eine der negativen
eigenschaften der deutschen man gönnt
anderen den erfolg nicht das ist ich bin
öfter im jahr in los angeles mein mann
lebt dort und da geht man ganz anders
mit um das ist auch sehr protzig und
sehr neureich europäisch verhältnisse
aber mir ist das sympathischer wenn
leute erfolg haben den usa auch sehr oft
selfmade gerade in los angeles wo man
sich neu erfindet wenn man dahin zieht
und uns selbst was erreicht warum sollen
wir nicht zeigen ich möchte nicht in den
weißen rolls royce mit roten ledersitzen
durch die gegend fahren aber wenn man
das möchte dann soll man das tun
die deutschen sind da wahrscheinlich
besonders hämisch wobei ich sagen muss
also bei boris becker so hart und so
böse wie die britische yellow press
sozusagen mit ihren eigenen stars umgeht
da hatte boris becker bei uns noch gut
getroffen da ist nur das sentiment der
leute irgendwie ein bisschen anders aber
gut ist abschließend ist es nämlich
schon am